conseil des ministres aides à l'emploi
et aux entreprises
israël une campagne mouvementée
ariane jour j moins deux
bonsoir je vous prie de l'excuser ce
petit incident technique au monde de la
lecture des titres réunion du conseil
des ministres ce matin au palais de
l'élysée de nouvelles mesures
économiques et sociales ont été adoptées
elles concernent principalement l'aide
aux entreprises et l'insertion
professionnelle nous les analyserons
bien sûr dans un instant car avant de
présenter les résultats des travaux du
conseil le secrétaire général de
l'elysée pierre bérégovoy a lu le texte
d'une déclaration prononcée par le
président de la république par son vote
du 10 mai le peuple français m'a confié
la charge d'engager notre pays sur la
voie d'une nouvelle politique c'est ce
qui a été fait dans tous les domaines et
dans la mesure où la constitution le
permettait par le gouvernement le 14
juin un nouvel élan a été donné je suis
persuadé que les françaises et les
français ne s'arrêteront pas là
au terme d'un long débat démocratique
qui a fait honneur à la république
française
ils manifesteront je le souhaite
dimanche prochain leur volonté de me
donner sur les bases les plus larges les
moyens de mener l'action utile cohérente
et durable
qu'appelle la situation de la france le
suffrage universel s'étant prononcé tous
les engagements pris seront tenus dans
cet esprit j'entends que l'opposition
soit respectée et associés comme il se
doit aux responsabilités que suppose le
bon fonctionnement du parlement
les principales mesures adoptées ce
matin elle concerne donc l'aide aux
entreprises l'accès au crédit sera
facilitée et l'insertion professionnelle
6 milliards seront consacrés à ces
dispositions qui concernent environ six
cent mille personnes
le gouvernement a décidé de porter à 17
milliards l'enveloppent total des prêts
bonifiés aux entreprises une partie de
cette somme 6 milliards 500 millions est
réservé à des supers près de plus les
entreprises qui solliciteront des prêts
avant le 30 septembre 80
bénéficieront de taux d'intérêt
avantageux 12,75 et 14 75%
enfin les comités départementaux de
financement pourront accorder des
avances de trésorerie à des entreprises
industrielles avance qui pourront
atteindre 500 mille francs
le deuxième train de mesures concerne
l'emploi il permettra d'embaucher 650
mille jeunes dès septembre prochain
parmi les dispositions adoptées on peut
citer l'exonération de la moitié des
cotisations patronales à la sécurité
sociale en cas d'embauché de jeunes de
moins de 26 ans
le développement des contrats emploi
formation dont la durée sera allongée de
un à deux ans le maintien des
exonérations en faveur des apprentis et
celui de la prime accordée pour l'en
bouche d'un premier salarié dans
l'artisanat
enfin les jeunes femmes bénéficieront
d'au moins 60% des stages et des
contrats emploi formation
après ces mesures gouvernementales une
réaction de la confédération des petites
et moyennes entreprises et les ouates un
effort en direction des pme mais il
reste insuffisant ajoute le communiqué
les dispositions concernant l'emploi ont
été commentés cet après midi par le
ministre du travail jean auroux a
rappelé les objectifs du gouvernement en
cette matière l'objectif que nous avons
recherché qui est celui du gouvernement
depuis un mois et de répondre à la tente
des jeunes qui espèrent et ils sont 650
mis dans cette situation qui espère que
le gouvernement va répondre à leurs
attentes en ce qui concerne un emploi à
la rentrée et je demande aux
collectivités locales au secteur
associatif aux chefs d'entreprise aux
directions du personnel de
d'ores et déjà de prendre toutes les
dispositions nécessaires pour répondre
aux dispositifs que nous venons de
lancer dans lequel large l'état
s'implique d'une façon non négligeable
sur le plan budgétaire et nous pensons
que les effets conjugués de
l'augmentation du pouvoir d'achat par le
biais du smig et la revalorisation d'un
certain nombre de prestations par le
biais des aides que nous avons mises en
place pour les entreprises notamment les
petites et moyennes entreprises et ce
dispositif pour l'emploi des jeunes
élargie à d'autres catégories devraient
normalement stabiliser une courbe
inquiétante de l'emploi et nous pensons
dans les deux ans renversé la tendance
par ailleurs trois nominations sont
intervenus ce matin au conseil des
ministres pierre marion à la tête du
sdec c'est le service de
contre-espionnage il succède à alexandre
de marenches michel caste devient
président directeur général de la
sofirad après la démission de xavier
gouyou beauchamps
enfin l'inspecteur général de la
gendarmerie le général jacques boyer
devient général de corps d'armée dans la
gendarmerie
l'actualité électorale dimanche prochain
6 120 candidats solliciteront les
suffrages des électeurs dans les
circonscriptions métropolitaines dix
d'entre eux n'ont pas de souci à se
faire il reste seul en lice
on compte par ailleurs 300 duels et une
élection triangulaire dans le bas rhin
et dans la perspective de ce second tour
de l'élection législative le premier
ministre pierre mauroy fait aujourd'hui
une déclaration à l'hôtel matignon
il ya eu dans le résultat de dimanche
une dimension morale les françaises et
les français n'ont pas cru que nous
allions fermer les écoles privées leur
interdire de consulter leur médecin de
famille ou confisquer leurs terres aux
agriculteurs et ils ont raison
or voici que cette campagne d'affolement
rebondit entre les deux tours même si
elle change de plan sous prétexte du
succès électoral remporté il ya quatre
jours par le parti socialiste
les dirigeants de la droite nous répète
sur tous les tons
que dimanche soir la france va devenir
un état socialiste dans la bouche de
ceux qui fondèrent avant-hier l'état du
dr ou même l'état giscardien l'argument
ne manque pas de sel
je veux être parfaitement clair nous
n'emploierons pas demain les méthodes
ont eu l'air hier contre nous les
gouvernements de la vème république
ces méthodes viennent d'être nettement
condamnée par le pays
nous avons prouvé notre bonne foi en
nous abstenant de toute chasse aux
sorcières il en ira de même par la suite
le pluralisme les libertés seront non
seulement respectée mais enrichit la
campagne électorale du côté du rpr et de
l'udf maintenant pour bernard pons pour
le rpr l'élection d'une majorité
socialo-communiste ne fait pas de doute
mais il a lancé un appel aux
abstentionnistes du premier tour et puis
pour jacques chirac il n'y a pas dit il
de combat perdu d'avancé le maire de
paris a repris son tour de france pour
soutenir les candidats de lui-même en
ballotage enfin pour l'udf michel pinçon
le délégué général a fait une
déclaration depuis le jeudi 28 mai 1981
le nouveau gouvernement essaie de
concilier l'inconciliable relancer
l'économie et en même temps défendre le
franc concilier l'inconciliable
c'est exactement ce que nous disons
maintenant depuis plusieurs mois
en parlant de la politique que propose
le gouvernement socialiste
et il se trouve qu'aujourd'hui les
observateurs honnêtes mais qui
n'appartiennent pas à nos formations
disent la même chose alors sans vous la
faire d'esprit partisan je crois qu'il
faut que les français sachent
aujourd'hui que la politique qui est
proposé est une politique qui ne peut
nous conduire qu'à l'échec économique
d'ores et déjà les promesses qui avaient
été faites aux fonctionnaires
n'ont pas pu être tenue aujourd'hui
bientôt on verra que toutes les mesures
proposées pour la relance économique ou
pour l'augmentation du pouvoir d'achat
ou telle ou telle catégorie sont
également des mesures illusoire ce n'est
plus seulement nous qui le disons
et il faut que dimanche prochain les
français nous donne les forces
nécessaires pour empêcher cette
évolution catastrophique la suite de
l'actualité politique maintenant avec
notre invité ce soir georges lavaud qui
est directeur de la revue française de
science politiques et professeur à
l'institut d'études politiques de paris
changera vous qui êtes un bon analyste
du parti communiste français auxquels
vous avez consacré un ouvrage à quoi
sert le parti communiste français
un ouvrage publié chez fayard cet
ouvrage vous l'avez édité à la fin de
l'année dernière la fin de l'année 1980
alors aujourd'hui à la même question à
quoi sert le parti communiste français
est ce que vous apporterez la même
réponse
là tu le thème général de mon livre
était que en dépit d'une représentation
certaines d'une certaine classe ouvrière
par le parti communiste et par la cgt
le bilan de l'activité du parti
communiste était finalement relativement
stérile pour les catégories sociales
qu'ils prétendaient représenter et de ce
point de vue je ne changerai pas mes
conclusions pas plus que je ne
changerais au contraire j'accentue ray
l'hypothèse que je faisais d'un déclin
qui me paraissaient durable du parti
communiste alors cette hémorragie
électoral que l'on a constaté à deux
reprises ou une élection présidentielle
au premier tour
et puis également au premier tour de
l'élection législative est ce que
d'après vous c'est un phénomène
irréversible est ce que ses électeurs
qui attend banques qui ont abandonné le
parti communiste pour se reporter dès le
premier tour sur le candidat socialiste
ou sur les candidats socialistes parce
que ces électeurs sont définitivement
perdus pour le pc d'après vous on ne
peut jamais dire qu'un phénomène est
irréversible et je me garderai de faire
des prévisions certaines ce qui me
semble notamment c'est que jamais
lorsque le parti communiste a connu un
fléchissement net comme en 1958 il n'est
revenu au niveau qu'il avait atteint
avant cette faille est cette fois ci la
faille est encore plus sérieuse que
celle qu'il avait frappé en 1959
58 et je pense d'ailleurs que les
élections du lys l'atvs le démontre que
on est en présence d'un phénomène qui
sauf en cas d'échec flagrant de
l'expérience du gouvernement socialiste
peut être durable alors les dirigeants
communistes indique annonce déjà que dès
le lendemain du second tour ils vont se
réunir pour conduire une réflexion en
commun sur la stratégie alors à ses
ennemis pour cent des voix avec une sous
représentation parlementaire environ 40
45 sièges d'après les projections les
estimations elles sont les différentes
stratégies qui sauf à ce parti
communiste français aujourd'hui bien il
faudrait attendre évidemment les
réunions du parti communiste et
éventuellement un congrès qui
normalement doit se tenir en mai 1982
mais on peut que même faire un certain
nombre de prévisions je pense que au
moins pendant une période qui peut durer
de un à deux ans en fonction des
événements de la conjoncture économique
le parti communiste sera relativement
contraint d'adopter une attitude
relativement prudente et un profil
relativement effacé se contentant de
manifester un soutien de principe à
l'expérience
je pense également que malgré tout il
agira avec le secours de la cgt beaucoup
plus libre puisqu'elle n'a pas de
responsabilité politique et qui sur son
terrain syndical choisira je pense un
certain nombre de points relativement
exemplaire pour maintenir une pression
suffisamment constante discrète ou moins
discrète selon encore une fois la
conjoncture mais que le pc et la cgt
voudront appelé malgré tout qu'ils
avaient leurs programmes qu'ils ont
leurs exigences et qu'ils ne sont pas
des alliés inconditionnels
alors une question dans réponse ne vous
appartient pas bien sûr mais c'est le
problème de la participation éventuelle
des communistes au gouvernement d'après
vous si la proposition lors été faite
par le parti socialiste et par le
président de la république est ce que le
parti communiste d'après ce que vous
savez de lui ah ouais t'as intérêt à
participer elle l'accepterait a
finalement dit qu'il regrettait la
proposition qui lui avait été faite en
36 par léon blum
il a tellement demandé qu'il y ait des
ministres communistes gouvernent
depuis 1974 il a tellement affirmé que
c'était la condition nécessaire du
changement qui me paraît difficile
qu'ils refusent maintenant cette
proposition si elle lui est fait
je pense également qu'il peut y avoir
pour lui tout de même un certain intérêt
à une présence même très modeste au sein
du gouvernement
néanmoins si on regarde ses intérêts et
éventuellement les risques que cela
représente pour lui je me demande quelle
est véritablement son intérêt à accepter
une telle participation
mais je pense que de toute façon sa
participation n'implique pas qu'il
s'associerait à l'expérience quoi qu'il
arrive et pour une durée très longue il
n'est plus il ne sera pas lié même s'ils
acceptent une participation
georges lavaud je vous remercie
l'intersyndicale des journalistes de
l'audiovisuel a publié aujourd'hui un
communiqué dont je vous livre
l'essentiel personne ni homme politique
ni représentant d'un quelconque groupe
de presse n'est habilité à dicter aux
journalistes l'attitude qui doit être la
leur dans la couverture de l'actualité
le communiqué poursuit il semblerait que
de prétendus intervention émanant de
responsables politiques aient lieu
actuellement dans les rédactions de
l'audiovisuel l'intersyndicale vérifiera
désormais systématiquement toute
information faisant état d'une
quelconque pression
l'intersyndicale rappelle qu'elle s'est
toujours battu pour que les journalistes
soient à l'abri de toute pression d'où
qu'elle vienne
elle entend poursuivre cette action
contre tous ceux qui voudraient en
perpétuer des pratiques condamnables
aujourd'hui les députés européens ont
débattu de la peine de mort un vote
pourrait intervenir demain il serait
sans doute favorable à l'abolition chez
nos partenaires la peine de mort est
abolie juridiquement pour les uns
pratiquement pour les autres et c'est
donc la position des députés français
qui retenait aujourd'hui l'attention
dans l'esprit des auteurs de la
résolution il ne s'agit pas seulement
arrêter ou d'empêcher toute exécution
capitale dans les pays de la communauté
mais il s'agit aussi d'en arriver
progressivement à une modification des
législations là où celle ci prévoit
encore la peine de mort est précisément
les socialistes français s'appuie sur ce
point particulièrement pour souhaiter
l'ouverture rapide au parlement
celle d'un débat consacrant l'abolition
non seulement dans les faits mais aussi
dans le droit
ils ont quelques chances d'être entendus
si l'on sait que les libéraux français
soucieux jusqu'ici de respecter une
opinion publique qu'ils savent encore
défavorable admettre pourtant que
l'arrêt des exécutions si cela devait se
confirmer en france devra bien un jour
être admis dans le 3 seul michel
poniatowski chez les français quelques
parlementaires grecs et britanniques ont
estimé aujourd'hui que la peine de mort
devait être maintenue malgré tout dans
certains cas extrêmes le président
françois mitterrand pourrait se rendre
aux états unis cet été pour y rencontrer
le président reagan cette information a
été rendue publique aujourd'hui par le
ministre du commerce extérieur
michel jobert à l'étranger les députés
iraniens ont passé la journée à mettre
au point la procédure du débat destiné à
prononcer l'incompétence politique du
président ben ali ça dans le débat et le
vote doivent avoir lieu samedi on ne
sait toujours pas si le président de la
république bani sadr se rendra au
parlement pour le depuis le début de
l'offensive menée contre lui
il vit dans son propre pays en semi
clandestinité
toutes les modalités de ce débat de
samedi ont été fixés aujourd'hui par le
parlement iranien
les adversaires et les partisans de
monsieur bani sadr disposeront chacun de
cinq heures pour développer leurs
arguments
à l'issue du débat le vote sur la
compétence du président devrait être
sanctionné par les deux tiers au moins
des députés présents d'ores et déjà
l'issue de ce vote est acquise
étant donné l'écrasante majorité dont
dispose le parti islamique
ce vote de destitution surprendre à
d'autant moins dur est l'opinion kelly a
été préparé par des manifestations
quotidiennes d'hostilité à bani sadr
aujourd'hui même au tour du parlement un
millier de personnes défilaient pour
demander sa tête
les dignitaires religieux ont indiqué
que la destitution n'excluait pas du
reste que l'on entame contre le
président des poursuites judiciaires
quant à la relève du pouvoir elle sera
assurée pour un intérim de 50 jours par
un conseil provisoire qui organisera
l'élection du successeur de bani sadr le
fait que nous soyons en guerre a dit
aujourd'hui l'ayatollah piège qui
n'empêche en rien le déroulement d'un
tel scrutin
demain le washington post publiera une
interview de françois mitterrand dans ce
texte le président la république
exposera la position française dans la
crise du proche orient après le raid
contre tamouz au conseil de sécurité
justement le représentant d'israël a
indiqué que son gouvernement ne paierait
pas un sou de réparation pour la
destruction de la centrale nucléaire
irakienne
cette déclaration israélienne était une
sorte de réponse à l'intervention du
représentant de la france jacques le
prêtre avait en effet demandé qu'israël
versent des réparations israël justement
où la campagne électorale s'intensifie
le vote pour l'élection des députés à la
knesset aura lieu le 30 juin prochain
une campagne particulièrement dure à
l'occasion de laquelle la violence en
veille le débat politique dans un
instant
il ne se passe pas de jours en israël
sans que le parti travailliste shimon
peres subissent des attaques menées par
des partisans de menahem begin mise à
sac répétées des bureaux de l'opposition
violence physique exercée sur des
militants hier encore une femme âgée a
été brutalisée après son intervention
télévisée
la démocratie est en danger affirme
depuis deux semaines shimon peres
il a vigoureusement dénoncé cette
violence générée par des jeunes gens ils
reçoivent directement leurs ordres du
gouvernement a précisé le chef de
l'opposition
c'est aussi l'avis de l'état major de la
police israélienne
il vient d'indiquer qu'une grande partie
de la violence électorale et organisé
campagne virulente doublée d'une
étonnante démonstration de force de la
part du premier ministre
tous les moyens sont bons pour mener le
parti du likoud de la victoire aux red
sur le liban a succédé la tacc du
réacteur irakien
ce dernier coup de force a rehaussé le
prestige de menahem begin
il relève la tête donné pendant pendant
il ya moins de six mois
il est aujourd'hui le favori c'est après
demain le 19 juin que la fusée ariane
sera mise à feu sur la base de kourou
les conditions météorologiques sont très
favorables une revue de détail s'est
révélée concluante le compte à rebours
pourra donc commencer dès demain un
dossier spécial ariane préparé par
daniel du rendu
bonsoir feu vert pour ariane le lanceur
européen qui attend protéger dans sa
tour d'acier l'heure décisive du
lancement en moins de douze heures va
commencer le compte à rebours une
opération en préliminaires au tir de ce
troisième modèle de qualification
d'ariane si toutes les opérations
continuent à se dérouler normalement
comme c'est le cas actuellement le tir
d'ariane aura bien lieu comme prévu
vendredi à 13h20 heure de paris avant de
vous présenter le but de cette nouvelle
mission d'ariane un petit portrait de ce
cap canaveral européen qui est court où
situez vous le rappelle à 7000
kilomètres de la métropole en guyane
française
sur la pointe nord de l'amérique du sud
le centre spatial guyanais c'est un
vaste complexe moderne
s'étendant sur une large savane de 15
kilomètres de laon d'un côté la forêt
amazonienne de l'autre l'océan
atlantique c'est à dire des possibilités
de lancement tous azimuts dans le quart
nord-est
autre avantage de poids sa position à 5
degrés nord donc pratiquement sur
l'équateur permet de bénéficier ici de
l'effet de fronde du à la rotation de la
terre et donc de pouvoir lancer avec la
même puissance des satellites 15% plus
lourd la cap canaveral créée il ya 13
ans kourou a connu des heures de gloire
avec le programme diamants et les
déboires cuisant avec repas aujourd'hui
l'espoir s'appelle ici ariane
le lanceur de l' agence spatiale
européenne le centre nerveux de
l'ensemble de lancement
c'est ce bloco souterrain situé à moins
de 200 mètres du pas de tir d'ariane ici
pendant 27 heures et 30 minutes du
compte à rebours on effectuera toutes
les opérations techniques jusqu'à la
mise à feu automatique par ordinateur de
la fusée
à une vingtaine de kilomètres de là la
ville de kourou une ville champignon
tout en béton avec de part et d'autre de
petits villages peuplée d'indiens et de
saramaca ici vivent en permanence tout
au long de l'année avec leurs familles
les 600 ingénieurs et techniciens du
centre spatial guyanais en poste pour
trois ou six ans à kourou on ne vit que
par et pour ariane c'est dire que la
plage de sable blanc longeant la ville
est baigné toute l'année par une douce
moiteur au sian invariablement entre 25
et 30 degrés restera déserte jusqu'au
tir ce troisième quart darian revêt une
importance capitale pour l'avenir du
programme européen et cela pour deux
raisons d'abord ariane doit maintenant
absolument convaincre ses futurs clients
de sa fiabilité et faire ainsi oublier
l'échec
il y a un an de 0,2 ensuite pour la
première fois ariane devra accomplir la
mission pour laquelle elle a été conçue
placé en orbite des satellites
cette image tout à fait exceptionnelle
d'ariane à laquelle il manque tout en
hausse à quoi fait les frais sur ces
listes et les phases de protéger a été
filmé il ya moins de 15 jours à coup
vous depuis on a procédé à l'intérieur
de la tour de lancement pressurisé à la
mise en place minutieuse et de
véritables premiers passagers d'ariane
les deux satellites apple et meteosat de
clients encore non payant d'ariane pour
la première fois on a utilisé ces deux
bâtiments appelés s3 pour l'intégration
finale et les cd 2 à tenir ses deux
premiers passages et les voici tout
d'abord au dessus de la capsule
technologique qui est le cerveau qui
guide les satellites après leur
séparation ariane apple
l'indien recouvert de feuilles d'or
c'est un satellite expérimental de
télécommunications précurseur la vaste
programme opérationnel
nous allons lancer dès l'année prochaine
satellites opérationnels puis un second
pour la télévision et les
télécommunications du programme insat de
notre télévision et un programme de
météo
apple justement nous aidera à préparer
ce lancement d'un satellite opérationnel
car en construisant apple nous avons
appris beaucoup pour la seconde
génération de satellites
c'est pourquoi nous attendons beaucoup
de ce lancement au dessus d'apple
meteosat 2 dans les panneaux solaires
sont encore recouverts de leurs
protections métalliques meteosat le
satellite européen qui doit contribuer à
une meilleure connaissance des
phénomènes météo et donc à leurs
prévisions plus précises
le satellite que nous allons lancer le
second du programme européen meteosat le
premier lancer en 77 de cap canaveral
par une fusée delta vient de terminer
son existence c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous avons décidé d'en lancer
un second
mais tout ça deux va prendre des images
de la terre toutes les deux mineures
depuis sa position à 3 degrés de
longitude qu'il atteindra en juillet
prochain
donc soit quinze jours après son
lancement
meteosat 2 sera donc situé sur le golfe
de guinée au niveau de l'équateur
ce sera la participation européenne au
programme du réseau mondial de
couverture métérologie observant en
permanence des masses nuageuses il
pourra permettre des prévisions météo
raisonnable à trois ou quatre jours avec
peu de chance d'erreurs à moins de 30
heures du tir j'ai pris deux mois sur le
site de lancement d'ariane
andré payet le chef de mission et 0,3
andré payet ou en étant actuellement à
moins de 30 heures de tirs eh bien nous
entrons dans la phase de préparation
finale du lanceur et les satellites et
nous sommes prêt ou presque il reste à
inspecter le troisième étage a armé le
lanceur pour les différentes séparation
des tâches et les commandes
pyrotechniques et après nous rentrons
dans la chronologie proprement dite
c'est à dire jeudi matin donc seules
petites préoccupations à la limite le
troisième étage la pression on en a plus
non plus aucun doute sur le troisième
étage
nous en sommes actuellement en train de
définir ses limites opérationnelles mais
tout est clair en début de semaine vous
avez effectué la dernière répétition
appelé répétition générale comment ça se
passait très bien passé je crois que là
on est satisfait sur le plan du centre
spatial guyanais du lanceur et des
satellites
là on est très très heureux si j'avais
dû tirer aujourd'hui à 8h20 ça serait
bien passé il aurait aucun problème nous
avions vraiment un beau un temps
excellent et les contraint de sauvegarde
était respectée donc optimiste très très
optimiste je vous donne maintenant
rendez-vous à demain soir nous serons
dans le centre de contrôle du centre
spatial guyanais et nous pourrons vivre
ainsi ensemble les derniers préparatifs
à cette nouvelle fantastique aventure
européenne
bonsoir et à demain à demain les
résultats du loto il y avait un tirage
aujourd'hui je vous en communiqué
résultats le 1 le 13 le 16 le 18 le 38
le 42e et le numéro complémentaire le 48
jeunes encore vous dire que notre
confrère louis berio a été élu
aujourd'hui président de l'association
espace pour demain et demain justement
le temps sera frais et souvent nuageux
avec quelques averses sur le nord-est et
la corse quelques chutes de pluie sont
également prévus près de la manche
les températures seront dans l'ensemble
inférieure à la normale saisonnière
ce journal est maintenant terminée je
vous remercie de nous avoir prêté
attention dans quelques instants and
lefébure vous indiquera les programmes
de demain sur notre antenne 2 fr3 je
vous souhaite de passer une excellente
nuit